Hey youtubers, what’s up.
This is going to be my Last Airbender Episode
1 and 2 video.
The first two episodes were really designed
to be aired back to back so it just works
better if I do them in the same video.
Hello to any new people, If you just found
me I’m re-watching all of last airbender
and doing videos for the episodes just like
I did for Korra.
And a weekly giveaway that I’ll explain
at the end of this.
I’ll start by saying spoiler warning, just
in case you haven’t seen these first two
yet.
TOP 5 Moments -
Number 5 - Katara’s Intro Sequence
I’m one of those people that only found
the series after it aired on TV.
So by the time I saw it, I already knew who
Mae Whitman was.
She had already done Johnny Bravo and bunch
of other voice over work.
But she’s got one of those voices that’s
so much fun to listen to.
Right now she’s doing the voice of April
O’Neil on Ninja Turtles, which is also airing
on Nickelodeon.
I know some of you are fans of that.
The Intro sequence also became a huge calling
card for the series in general, so much so
that they kept it when they produced Legend
of Korra.
It works perfectly as an explainer for people
who have never seen the series before and
just looks damn beautiful.
And I could spend all day listening to the
music score.
If you saw the unaired pilot.
They changed a lot and you can tell why.
The final version of the intro speeds through
a lot of the exposition in the pilot.
Explaining the 100 year war and differentiating
the characters.
On top of that, the intro for the very first
episode Boy in the Iceberg, was extra long.
They shortened the intro a little with subsequent
episodes just because they only have 22 minutes
to tell a story.
So shorter intros mean more time with the
characters.
And long intros get kind of repetitive after
a while.
The era of the Netflix marathon watch has
made that pretty clear.
Number 4 - Keeping Your Weirdness to Yourself
and Aang Gets Unfrozen
I like the way they connect the idea of expressing
yourself with bringing the Avatar back into
the world.
If Katara had listened to Sokka and supressed
her bending there’s a good chance the Aang
would have stayed frozen in the ice for who
knows how long.
Bryke is trying to communicate that being
creative and putting yourself out there is
a good thing and you shouldn’t listen to
trolls.
Represented in this scene by Sokka.
Sokka did do a lot of Bender Trolling early
on but I never thought of him as an antagonist.
I think up in his headspace he was trying
to deal with being the new man of the house
after their parents died, despite the fact
Katara was really the brains of that operation.
Aang’s return was also one of the first
big action set pieces of Book 1.
Every time I rewatch it I’m always surprised
by how quickly he jumps into casual conversation,
like it’s no big deal he just walked out
of a giant block of ice.
I think they wanted to start the series off
on a postive upbeat note just to get you more
excited for the hero.
But if you think about the circumstances that
put him in the ice it’s a little inconsistent.
He ran away after they told him he was the
new Avatar, flew into a storm and passed out
when he and Appa hit the water.
So he would have been super scared.
The natural reaction after being unfrozen
would be to scream in terror, because you’d
be locked into the original moment you passed
out.
So let’s just say TV Logic hand-waving.
There was no way they were going to start
the series off on a bummer moment and freak
little kids out by having the hero scream
in terror the first time you meet him.
Number 3 - Zuko’s Intro
I wasn’t a huge fan of Book 1 Zuko but that’s
because Bryan and Mike did their job so well.
You are supposed to not like Zuko, he’s
the antagonist of Book 1.
Even Iroh is like “dude, chill out and have
some tea”.
We’re on an extended vacation.
You guys can let me know if you agree, but
don’t you feel like when a villain complains
too much or gets casually dismissed like Zuko
in this scene.
You automatically stop thinking of him as
an insurmountable threat.
He’s still a threat, at this point in the
series he’s not quite as good a bender as
Azula but he’s still really good.
Little character quirks like this feel normal
for a children’s animated series.
It’s like producers want kids to be afraid
without thinking things are completely hopeless.
That comes later.
Hopelessness comes later at the end of Book
2 in the crystal caves.
Number 2 - Zuko versus the Water Tribe
I’m surprised Sokka didn’t paint his face
more later in the series when they knew they
were walking into battles.
He looks pretty badass with it on.
And the stand off with Zuko was a great hero
moment for him.
It was a lot easier to give Sokka big moments
like this before Toph came along.
It’s like the Justice League before Superman
and Batman get there.
Once they show up, the benchmark for heroic
acts goes way up.
That’s a whole other conversation, non-benders
in the avatar world can still have those big
hero moments when they stand next to Aang
or Korra but usually it’s only when they
sacrifice themselves.
When you think about it, there’s very little
risk to an Avatar getting into a fight when
they have nearly unlimited power.
and
my number 1 moment - Aang Escapes with Sokka
and Katara
This is the official beginning of Team Avatar
and the first big Aang versus Zuko fight.
And the second big Avatar State moment.
He was in the avatar state when he emerged
from the ice in episode 1.
Bryan and Mike said that one of the big aspects
of the series Nickelodeon asked for was Action
without Violence.
That’s where the idea of bending elements
came in.
So everyone wasn’t stabbing, slicing or
sawing each other in half.
Bloodless action.
I’m always curious why more people would
get turned into fried chicken
with all that fire.
Here’s my question for you guys, what’s
your favorite moment from the first two episodes
and what did you think of the characters at
this point.
Before you saw the rest of the series.
I want to try something new with my Avatar
Episodes.
Instead of just giving them a rating like
I normally would I’m going to do thumbs
up thumbs down.
I might start doing top 5 thumbs up top 5
thumbs down from now on.
Thumbs Down for What
I’m not going to be too hard on the way
the characters reacted to situations or the
voice actors since this is a series made for
children and performed mostly by children.
My only thumbs down are the lack of complexity
in the minor characters like the water tribe
crowd scenes and inconsistency in Sokka’s
character.
I feel like Sokka is undiagnosed bipolar.
At this point in the series, he’s a catch
all reaction gif for every twist in the plot.
So I understand the role he serves and that’s
why I think he over-emotes and jumps from
really happy to depressed in the span of a
few minutes.
I don’t think that’s completely necessary
but it’s a cartoon inspired by anime so
I they were just doing their version of the
hyperbolic anime reaction.
When the got to Korra the execution on those
types of visual gags was way better.
I think it’s more a sign of the overseas
animation.
If you’ve ever listened to the audio commentaries
on the Korra DVDs, Bryan and Mike talk a lot
about visual things they wanted to do on Last
Airbender that they just couldn’t get but
when they got to Korra, Studio Miir was totally
able to pull off what they asked
for in terms of the animation.
I’ll probably post my next Avatar Episode
in a week.
I’ll try to get these up every 7 or 8 days.
And if you don’t know what’s going on
with the weekly giveaway.
It’s just a $20 amazon giftcard once a week.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
Congrats to this week’s winner, my violet
tears.
Please message me on my channel for details.
Thanks.
If you guys haven’t seen, because a lot
of tv shows are coming back like Arrow, Flash,
Game of Thrones and everything else.
I’ll be posting a lot of trailer videos
in the next week or two.
So look out for that stuff.
I’m pretty good about posting my schedule
every day on facebook and twitter.
Right now click here to learn all about the
creation of the Avatar Series behind the scenes
and click here for all my Korra Videos.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!